we created a new series called five and
five it was a very simple premise we
gave a wack Packer the opportunity to
interview their favorite celebrity with
five questions in five minutes they get
five minutes with a celebrity the first
series was Mark the bagger interviewing
his crush his the love of his life Nikki
Glazer yes for those of you who don't
remember it it was this do you have a
shaved pory or an unshaved
py um okay uh I it depends on the day
right now I think it's I think it's
shaved I just want to be honest with you
you know like that's you took a chance
and asking a very bold question and most
I think people would say I'm not
answering that but I it's shaved right
now uh because I thought I was going to
get some the other day cool cool not
from you Mark it's not so
cool well celebrities agree to do this
because we promise it it will only take
5 minutes and we do hold uh you there's
never been a celebrity so far that said
Gee let's go a few more minutes cuz this
is so
fascinating yeah so medicated Pete
interviewed Andy con medicated Pete got
his name because um he takes a lot of
medications for his tourettes for his
anxiety and uh if you remember medicated
Pete is also obsessed with the fact that
he has a huge penis and uh here's how
medicated Pete opened up the show here
we go it's time
for
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody medicated
Pete this is a five and five my host
today is Andy Cohen of course you can
see him here on Sirius at um and radio
Andy he says my host today is Andy in of
he's so bad at it but it's great he's
great at it actually the best thing I've
ever heard sorry let's get back to the
action also um you know he's the
housewife guy yeah executive producer of
The Housewives yeah so with that said
Andy I got to ask you some some pretty
uh pretty hard-headed questions here
what's your um like seriously what what
would your what what would your ideal
length of [__] be my like [__] like a
beautiful lengthy [__] that's
interesting what is your what's what
what's your what's your number you think
what's my number yeah yeah I'm going to
say oh my God uh I'm GNA say anything
over having is fun that would be that
would be cool with you I mean uh that
that sounds pretty pretty cool yeah yeah
yeah I mean uh what's yours so it's
about that I mean I I I I I have a I
have a but youing pretty decent size but
okay oh really are you well are you well
endowed yes I am really
yeah it quickly turns to Pete's penis
yeah all of a sudden Pete is being
interviewed I think ped has a crush on
Andy he's a good sport uh he wasn't
thrown I was I was uh going to wait to
see his reaction he was not thrown no he
doesn't get thrown by this stuff uh so
Pete continued with his questions for
Andy don't forget he only gets five
questions so here we go so listen so
hypothetically we're on a new beach you
and I okay wow and um and you know these
tents have these tents on these beaches
on these nude beaches are you familiar
with that no well anyway you can go back
to these tents and and they can like you
know they can suck you off or whatever
these people okay so would you
hypothetically would you would you take
me back to a tent and maybe maybe you
like to play with it a little bit you're
asking me if I would blow you in one of
those tents right well I would really
need to see what I'm dealing with in
order to you know what I mean like I I I
don't know it's I'm open to it Pete I'm
open to it it depends where my head was
at that day so really the two of us
we're we're we're on a date okay okay so
how would I how would I incorporate like
having a large penis in a conversation
like between hypothetically between the
two of us to so the idea is that you
want the person that you're on the date
with to know that you're well endowed
right if you were with me I think you
could say to me you know Andy I have a
very large [__] and I would want to talk
about that with a woman I would want you
to be very delicate and I would want you
to say you know maybe you say Do you
believe it's about the mo of the ocean
or the size of the vessel maybe that's
kind of a fun way to get into it right
wow Andy's like uh Pete's life coach all
right well uh all good things have to
come to an end and this is good how far
are we into
this uh here's Pete's last two questions
including a bonus question that shocked
us all most shocking five and five um
which which house do you think would uh
would enjoy playing with with my coog do
you think you think you know that's a
tough question Pete uh there's one that
I'm thinking of who's a former housewife
but I don't want to put words in her
mouth you have to think about that what
yeah you you'd have to think about it I
would yeah yeah yeah I think it's
interesting that these are all [__]
related questions that you have for me
yeah yeah but we we're what we're kind
of looking for these like hard hitting
questions and and have you ever done
anything with a guy no but but um but
you're interested to know if I would
blow you on a n Beach I've been on new
beaches so so yeah so yeah oh so yes you
have yeah okay okay one minute left you
you like girth or L sure um I just think
it depends on the on what I'm looking at
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I guess um I
guess can I ask you a a a blunt question
yeah can I show you my pains you want to
show it to me yeah can I possibly get
the Andy Cohen seal approval here
um I mean is it an HR issue it seems I
think maybe you I think maybe you
shouldn't show it to me right now okay
yeah yeah all right yeah I can I am I
mean I will say that I'm not leaving
without a sense of curiosity here
because you're touting it you're talking
it up you're really talking it up and
you really want to show it to me it it
it is pretty impressive I I think so
anyway wow all right the funny thing is
we told Pete ahead of time he's not
allowed to show his penis even if Andy
asked for it and that went right out the
window you can't tell Pete that that
that he doesn't that doesn't even
register with him yeah because Pete
heard you're allowed to show your penis
to
Andy that's he didn't hear the knot but
I gotta say something to Andy right now
you're a great sport you really are I I
love you and I think that it was very
kind of you to sit there for a medicated
you know you got a major career going
and you know sitting there yeah and
sitting there with medicated it was five
and five I did it on my way out of the
building uh you know it was five and
five it was the pitch is very good it's
you you you get in and out but then I
mean I'm telling you he was moments away
from unbuttoning his pants I felt like
all before noon I I I got I was like am
I getting what is happening here
all right Andy appreciate you being such
a good sport I really truly do thank you
you thank you
Pete